you people is definitely hilarious and
often super cringe in like the best way
but it's even more funny behind the
scenes for real these comedy Legends
cannot stay in character and end up
saying some of the most ridiculous lines
that honestly should have absolutely
been left in the film looking at you
Jonah see you can't really make this up
Jonah is really my homeboy in real life
like I love me some Donahue it's
hilarious how well it ended up working
out because their first meeting was not
so great get out when Lauren London was
on her way to a meeting with Jonah she's
blocked by this massive van in the valet
and she can't move past it I'm honking
like who is blocking the
well guess who steps out of the van and
if you guessed Jonah you'd be correct
and he comes out and he's like I'm so I
think I'm supposed to meet you today I'm
like oh you are kind of similar to the
way their characters met her
I'm so sorry now luckily Julia Louis
Dreyfus is nothing like Shelly but she
is given some top-tier marriage advice
right here my husband spoke out of turn
he does that on occasionally I love him
with all my heart but he should really
open his mouth Eddie Murphy definitely
struggled with his character at times
and honestly how could he not so you
drive a lot yeah when I want to get
somewhere
the fact that everyone else laughed
before Julia on this line about her dear
friend Becca Edgar Becca the races
The Improv is kinda everything and
there's a ton of it look I know there's
so much more that hasn't been released
again looking at you Jonah I'm never
gonna meet a woman who understands me
anyway yeah who else's favorite
character is Mo
not gonna lie though Shelly as
problematic as she is is definitely a
close second what did I push my ass
yeah no thank you can somebody answer me
how did they get anything done on this
set I always wanted to get married on
June 10th when I was a little girl I was
out
two things I want number one to know
exactly what Jonah Hill wanted when he
was a little girl and two all of the
deleted scenes in this movie all those
bones were built up if this [__] don't
work out tell it on a tree I really want
to see the entirety of this dinner scene
Mal found it real your lettuce is
cutting your gums I need a mouth Bandit
but there was also a ton of stuff that
was cut because of reasons you wouldn't
even think to be a factor which I'm
gonna go into more detail on that later
but for now we've uncovered the secret
tactic to pinning down this Stellar
comedy style when Eddie Murphy is
talking just listen as you're doing the
scenes the lines are there but you can
play Eddie would just say whatever
Eddie's a professional who's been doing
this for decades everything that comes
out of his mouth is probably gold Nia
Long says she couldn't keep a straight
face through most of their scenes and
her tactic was to listen to whatever he
said and just respond appropriately and
of course do her absolute best to stay
in character I I don't think I like that
one of the most difficult scenes for
everyone including the director Kenya
Barris was the first dinner scene you
would think it'd be one of the easier
sequences to get because everyone is
sitting in one place but yeah not so
much dinner scenes are impossible just
that one scene alone took an entire day
it was tough apparently though the best
parts of it were the moments in between
takes where everyone was laughing and
joking around that dinner though was
small potatoes compared to the scene at
the wedding table you know the scene bro
we just want to say congrats you
marrying this white man all these white
people hair every single speech was
fully improvised I stormed the capital I
did I was there it was a full day of
work but because of all the Improv it
was super light and comedic making it a
major favorite for everyone on set
another favorite for the cast was Ezra
meeting Amira's parents but like how
awkward was this scene to watch though
so do you hang out in the hood all the
time or do you just come up here for our
food and women for those of you who
haven't been to La Roscoe's Chicken and
Waffles is a real place maybe don't ask
for anyone's hand in marriage there but
definitely order some chicken anyway Nia
Long loved this scene and definitely
utilized her just listen to Eddie Murphy
technique here I was like oh my god I
think I'm gonna peel myself it was very
funny and speaking of Eddie let's get
into one of those major scenes that
ended up being cut because of him so
Eddie Murphy's been in so many movies
over the years the writers and producers
of you people had to adjust a few scenes
to make sure it wasn't too similar to
other movies he's been in one of the
most obvious ones is gonna be in the
barbershop scene how many of you have
seen Coming to America they ended up
cutting out a lot of comedy in the
beginning of his Barbershop scene
because it was way too similar to his
Coming to America Vibes am I white cuz
well I'm not I'm white guys for sure
when these legendary actors get on set
together magic happens and by Magic it's
giving incredible improv bloopers that
would make hilarious scenes and deleted
moments that actually make you love the
movie even more but what's your favorite
moment behind the scenes